[Musique]
prendre part à quelque chose comme ça
c'est vraiment pas rien tu es fier de
toi
[Applaudissements]
bonjour monsieur ce qui fabrique ces
engins doivent répondre de la mort de
vingt-quatre américain au cours des 12
derniers mois
finie tant que nous ne les trouveront
pas de nouveaux soldats américains
risquent de rentrer chez ce morceau qui
a envie de changer les choses
ça ne peut pas là comment très bien
marché pour moi tu vois quoi comme tu
sens bien c'est lui aa carnivores alors
messieurs
quel est le plan j'essaie d'établir une
relation il est sérieux la vie a envie
de s'amuser
j'arrive pas de penser à ce jeune qu'on
a tué aujourd'hui je pense que c'est mal
oui tout à fait en tuant des leurres tu
sauves 10 de notre théâtre que c'est mal
cet homme était il ne chante le méritait
pas de mourir puissant complice c'est
que tout ce qui se passe ici ça reste
dans la famille renvoi service va
chercher les cibles tu crois qu'on va
tirer dessus
et cette faire ce que tu penses être
juste mais problème c'est que tu sais
pas encore ce qui est mal je veux tout
seul tu es seul qui me semble juste au
risque de mettre en danger
est ce que je la ferme me donnez moi
votre loyauté et je vous garantis que
chacun d'entre vous aura l'occasion de
devenir un guerrier
faire partie de l'histoire signal 3
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]